today I'm going to bake this chocolate
cake now those of you who know me know
that the only reason I would do this is
to prove a point earlier I was asking
people to compare the temperatures of
these two objects a science book written
by Isaac Asimov and an old metal hard
drive can you compare their temperatures
oh yeah Khoda called and it's not it's
room temperature
can you notice a colder than that one
yeah what makes something hotter or
colder what it would affected the actual
material remains paper is warm and metal
is cold both of these objects have been
sitting here on the ground for quite a
while so one might expect that they're
at the same temperature no because this
is a metal and that's paper well what if
I left that outside all day would it be
15 degrees no because paper doesn't
absorb cold doesn't absorb cold no well
I've left books out not all day um
outdoors and I can't say that I've
noticed the book was cold when I've come
to pick it up ever what if I told you
that these two objects are actually the
same temperature
what would you say definitely not if the
temperature right now this is called up
so let's say you're taking a cake out of
the oven yeah would you be worried about
touching the cake
yes well not the cake itself but the
actual teen around the cake is you'll be
hot yeah but how does the temperature of
the tin compare to the temperature of
the cake well the cake will be a warlike
hot but not as hot as a tent the chimps
hotter because it's a metal metal of
metal holds the heat longer and holds
the cold longer like a tin would be the
same temperature as the cake what do you
think it's been like in 200 degrees
Celsius I would probably be the same but
it's somehow it just doesn't feel like
it will burn with metal whereas my
fingers will melt but I mean not if I
stick my finger in the cake it wouldn't
burn as much all right it's time to take
the cake out and find out if it's the
same temperature as the tin I have a
meat thermometer with which to measure
the temperature the cake I'm not sure
that's the most accurate way of doing it
but well it's the only thing I've got so
let's give it a shot so I tried to
measure the temperature of the cake
using a meat thermometer but
unfortunately its temperature scale
doesn't go high enough
to allow me to accurately measure the
temperature of the cake you can actually
hear the moment when I realized that my
experiment wasn't going to work uh-oh so
now I'm back in Vancouver and I thought
I'd bring in the big guns
to help me sort out this experiment and
buy the big guns I of course mean my mom
so Derek I understand we're gonna make
this vanilla cake mix together and see
what happens we've got a secret weapon
which is this infrared thermometer which
can measure temperatures up to 300
degrees Celsius so we should have no
problems with it we just pointed at a
surface and it gives us a readout of the
temperature of that surface so this
should be perfect for measuring the
temperature of the cake and the tin do
you want to make a prediction about the
relative temperatures of the cake and
the tin when we bring it out of the oven
well I really suspect that the tin is
going to be a lot hotter than the cake
you can really not handle the tin at all
so I I reckon that's what's gonna happen
okay well I think they're both going to
be the same temperature but I could be
wrong so we're gonna have to do the
experiment and find out all right let's
get mixing okay so it's been about a
half an hour and the cake is cooked it's
ready to come out
yeah we're all ready tinnitus your your
expert opinion as the master baker here
hey something says okay we're gonna take
the cake out of the oven and we're going
to check the temperature of the tin and
the cake let's do it okay
oh it looks like a good cake yeah not a
bad one okay so let's measure the
temperature of the cake we have 108
point 9 and the temperature of the tin
one one eight point six but dropping
over here 108 point one so we have what
would you say about the temperature the
cake in the tin pretty close much closer
than I expected
hmm they're quite similar they're both
around 110 yes Celsius that's my point
is that the tin in the cake are the same
temperature but the tin is going to
conduct heat to your hand much faster
than the cake so the 10 would burn you
but the cake would not but they're the
same temperature what if I were to
impress upon you that they are in fact
the same temperature
I'll take your word for it and and that
in fact these two are the same
temperature I don't agree with that you
don't think there's an extreme
temperature no Riley I just can't
believe this book is 15 degrees it just
doesn't feel it don't believe it in
truth there's no difference in the
temperature between these two objects if
they've been in the same surroundings
for a long period of time they come to
thermal equilibrium with their
surroundings which means they're both
the same temperature but the metal feels
colder because it's able to conduct heat
away from my hand faster than the book
so just because an object feels colder
that doesn't mean that it actually has a
lower temperature it may just mean that
it's conducting heat away from your hand
faster I say what's interesting isn't it
richest learn something